hey guys we're panning around because i
just wanted to want you to see what the
views look like it is just so beautiful
out there we've got the clouds we've got
the sun on the way up what's not so
pretty are the winds because those have
been up over 30 uh even 40 miles an hour
in the mountains now but even 30 plus in
the valley and then you get over here
where it's still a little darker where
the sunlight hasn't hit yet and it just
looks very ominous over the spring
mountains where we've got winter weather
advisories already in place we're
looking for valley rain mountain snow
today and lots of wind so it is going to
be a very unsettled day for us we're
still a couple of weeks away from fall
but it's going to feel a little more
wintry as we get this storm coming in
now the winds have been out of the west
southwest and they've been gusting as i
said in the valley 25 to 30 miles an
hour in some places 6 40 the sunrise 426
is the sunset then this system is
promising to bring better chances of
rainfall than what we had a couple of
days ago we'll take every drop we can
get and better snowfall in the mountains
snow levels down to six thousand feet
where we could see up to about nine
inches of snow in the higher elevations
if we're lucky maybe a little bit more
but maybe even five inches around 6000
feet now after this storm clears out
tonight and we have we're back to clear
skies tomorrow and colder temperatures
we've got a freeze watch posted for
tomorrow night into saturday morning and
morning lows will be down to 30's
freezing and below
that's for tomorrow night into saturday
night it's going to be a cold weekend
find some heavier blankets for the beds
and get those filters changed for the
heaters i think you're going to be using
them cold air plunging in from the
northwest behind this system that's got
a lot of moisture with it good snow in
the sierras rain in california and it's
all advancing towards the desert
southwest and whatever's left we get and
we're already starting to see on the
radar some green filling in so some
showers are trying to take shape up in
lincoln county the moapa valley now not
all of this is hitting the ground but at
least it's showing up on radar and the
mountains will be getting it first looks
like already a little snow is falling up
there winter weather advisories until
six o'clock tonight if you don't need to
be traveling in the mountains don't go
up there it's going to be a little
treacherous up there especially through
the day
highs in the mid 40s and we've already
hit those we're going to be dropping
into the 20s in the mountains through
the day with that colder air 59 for the
high for the valley rain likely through
the afternoon into the early evening
then the system's gone clear skies
through the weekend and another system
next week maybe even lower snow levels
we'll see if we get a few snow flurries
around the west side of the valley next
week